dans le dernier épisode je me suis
opposé à la méthode scientifique par p
value qui est aujourd'hui la plus
utilisée mais aussi la plus recommandée
dans les discours sur la méthode
scientifique
en bref je pense qu'il est grand temps
de bannières du langage scientifique des
notions comme statistiquement
significatifs preuve scientifique où
aucun effet n'a été détectée et plus
généralement je pense qu'il est temps de
renoncer à l'idée de sciences par
réfutation surtout par réfutation par
une sorte de tribunal qui serait
l'expérience randomisée en double
aveugle une expérience seule ne suffit
pas et tout méta analyse est
inéluctablement biaisé par les biais de
publications en fait de façon générale
bien déterminer ce qui peut être un
ferrer des données c'est à dire faire de
l'épistémologie c'est compliqué alors
revu de ce discours vous avez peut-être
du coup eu l'impression que je faisais
mon rebelles qui s'oppose à l'autorité
scientifique
sauf que pas du tout tout ce que j'ai
fait c'est finalement relais
l'exaspération croissante de très très
très nombreux statisticiens se poser à
la paix value est devenue une position
consensuelle
chez les statisticiens surtout
dernièrement et surtout en particulier
suite à une publication dans nos coeurs
co signée par 800 scientifiques en mars
2019 et surtout quand pendant ce temps
la revue scientifique via make une
statisticienne publié une édition
spéciale intitulée moving beyond the
world beyond pis mot love and fall of
life
en fait il ne me semble pas
déraisonnable d'affirmer que les
statistiques sont en train de traverser
une sorte de crise existentielle
en particulier il semble y avoir une
crise des fondements des statistiques
et vu que les sciences s'appuie
inéluctablement sur les statistiques
il ne me semble pas déraisonnable de
parler même de crise des fondements des
sciences pour appuyer ses propos
aujourd'hui je vous propose de découvrir
à quel point les statisticiens s'oppose
à la méthode scientifique souvent
préconisé aujourd'hui ainsi qu'à la
méthode qu'applique en pratique les
scientifiques d'aujourd'hui
voici des citations de statisticiens de
premier rang qui datent tous de mars
2010 9
le biais de publier uniquement les
résultats dont les paies valu aux tests
statistiques d'hypothèses nul est en
dessous du seuil communément admis de
0,05 ou 0,01 a rendu les chèques de
réplication inévitable à cause de la
régression à la moyenne c'est tout à
fait extraordinaire qu'un modèle
d'inférence qui résiste à
l'implémentation prescrites et qui joue
de toute façon un rôle très limité dans
le progrès scientifique a néanmoins
dominé les pages des journaux en
sciences sociales sciences du management
et en sciences biomédicales pendant des
décennies clairement une refonte
sérieuse de la réflexion autour du rôle
des statistiques de l'avancée
scientifique est requise de nos joueurs
de nombreux scientifiques sont formés
aux tests statistiques d'hypothèses nul
dans cette tradition
les études complexes ont résumé
principalement par une série de paix
value et celles ci sont ensuite
utilisées pour établir des jugements
catégorique
par exemple ce médicament marche où ce
médicament ne marche pas souvent avec
très peu voire aucune attention prêtée à
l'amp étude de l'effet
quelle est la taille des faits du
médicament ou à l'incertitude de la
généralisation à partir de l'échantillon
1 quel point les résultats pourraient
nous induire en erreur une utilisation
incorrecte des tests statistiques
d'hypothèses nul a certainement quelque
chose à voir avec la reproductibilité
l'un des plus récurrents contre sens par
exemple est le fait que la paix value
est une estimation de la probabilité que
l'hypothèse nul est vrai prétendre
qu'une hypothèse est fausse avec
probabilité 95% car une expérience a
conduit à une paix value de 0.05 s'est
effectué une déclaration irresponsable
au lieu d'un ference sur les paramètres
la vraie importance d'un traitement ou
d'un effet explicatif ne concerne que la
distribution des observable de plus le
but principal de l'inférence statistique
devrait être de prédire des valeurs
réalisable non encore observé à partir
des valeurs qui ont été observés alors
qu'une paix value ou en facteur de
bêtise peut être utile en tant que
simple résumé numérique
elle ne devrait pas être célébrée comme
la mère de toutes les statistiques de la
prise de décisions scientifiques
des débats animés ont eu lieu dans le
passé notamment entre fisher et jeffreys
est entré fisher et neiman même
aujourd'hui les débats paradigmatique ne
semble pas faiblir
que ce soit dans la littérature publiée
ou sur les réseaux sociaux
la significativité statistique n'est pas
une mesure de significativité pratique
clinique ou scientifique
tout faux positifs publiés dans la
littérature à comité de lecture fourni
des munitions à ceux qui s'opposent aux
sciences ceci n'a jamais été aussi
important il y a désormais une énorme
pression venant de l'intérieur et de
l'extérieur des sciences pour améliorer
la fiabilité des résultats publiés ce
que je propose c'est que les termes
significative est non significatif ne
soit plus utilisé du tout il y à de
nombreuses limitations abondamment
discuté de ces méthodes comme l'épée
value piégeuse mans très faible et non
ajustées pour tenir compte de
l'ajustement interactif et les mesures
biaisé air carré parmi d'autres nous
avons été si habitués à avoir notre
attention attirée par les niveaux de
significativité surligner comme le fait
que paix est inférieure à 0,05 que nous
sommes souvent devenu aveugle à des
choses plus grande est peut-être plus
importantes comme l'estimation du sens
profond de nos études les études d'un
phénomène psychologique données ne
peuvent jamais être des réplications
direct ou exact les unes des autres
par conséquent l'hétérogénéité ne peut
pas être évité plutôt que de chercher en
vain à l'éliminer nous proposons que des
projets de réplication à grande échelle
lembras dorénavant à travers la
variation systématique des facteurs de
la méthode
nous ne devrions pas nous cacher
derrière la diligence et la facilité
nous prétendons que les passions
accepterait un traitement à 50% de
chances de soigner le cancer du pancréas
alors que la plupart pourraient préférer
une probabilité de 95 % qu'un traitement
produisent une perte de 10 kg en une
année ces affirmations sont bien mieux
adapté pour être décrite comme l'effet
d'un traitement dans un paradigme
bayésiens le processus de tourner les
données en savoir et centrale à
l'entreprise scientifique
il est donc remarquable que l' approche
la plus utilisée les tests statistiques
d'hypothèses nul a été sujette à des
critiques dévastatrices depuis si
longtemps
avec si peu d'effet
je vais démontrer que dans le domaine de
l'éducation et d'autres disciplines
les tailles des faits comme les valeurs
des deux corps n ont été tout aussi
problématique que l'épée value pour
produire des découvertes erronées
concernant l'efficacité des
interventions tous les principaux
protocoles demande l'intervention de
beaucoup de ressources en particulier du
temps des experts de facilitateur et de
ceux qui organisent les licitation les
licitation ne devrait pas être vu comme
une option à faible coût cependant le
résultat est de l'information est licite
et d'experts de manière rigoureuse et
scientifique
il y à une mécompréhension persistantes
concernant la quantité de preuves
statistiques contenues dans les p va
lure et beaucoup de scientifiques sont
réluctance à ajuster leurs
interprétations dp value fondées sur des
mesures directes de données les
fréquentes east ont des procédures pour
choisir des modèles est estimée des
paramètres
les parisiens ont des procédures pour
calculer les probabilités a posteriori
des modèles étaient paramètres chaque
type de procédure peut sembler avoir
beaucoup de sens quand il ya beaucoup de
modèles et de paramètres cependant
souvent il n'y en a pas et prétendre le
contraire peut conduire à des erreurs
d'inférence car ceux-ci détourne
l'attention de la tâche souvent plus
crucial de trouver les bons modèles les
chercheurs académiques sont intéressés
par leur carrière parce que les
promotions dans le monde académique et
dépendent en grande partie des
publications les chercheurs académiques
ont d'énormes motivation à publier
du coup les éditeurs de journaux ont un
pouvoir énorme si les éditeurs de
journaux insistent sur des pratiques qui
sont bonnes pour la science les auteurs
vont s'ajuster et la science en
bénéficiera conformément au contraire un
manquement à insister sur les bonnes
pratiques des sciences et même une
insistance sur des pratiques néfastes à
la science comme les tests statistiques
d'hypothèses nul se fera sans surprise
au détriment de la science
même ceux qui considère néanmoins l'épée
value comme des outils pour séparer les
résultats qui demandent plus d'études de
ceux qui sont purement dû à la chance
sont généralement d'accord pour dire que
l'épée value sont inutiles si elles ne
sont pas analysés dans le contexte
adapté est calculée à partir d'études
conçu de manière appropriée au cours des
dernières années une série d'exemples
très publicisée combinée à des travaux
théoriques ont montré clairement que les
résultats statistiquement significatifs
peuvent être obtenues à partir de pure
bruit les tentatives précédentes
d'adressé ce problème en particulier le
détournement et l'abus croissant des
tests statistiques d'hypothèses nul et
l'omniprésente paix value on était
totalement inefficace
la contribution que vous lisez fourni
des éléments empirique qui le montrent
de façon plus spécifique
nous montrons qu'une série d'articles
très cité et de livres qui est exposé
les faiblesses fondamentales
les tests statistiques d'hypothèses nul
et leurs effets néfastes sur le
développement du savoir ont néanmoins
été incapable d'empêcher leur essor
inexorable dans les sciences sociales et
de management
au cours de la période 1960 2007
le problème est que l'épée value ont des
mauvaises performances dans la tâche qui
leur est donné elle confond de taille
des faits et précision rendant confuse
l'emphase naturel sur les tailles des
faits importants
elles dépendent de la conception
expérimental prévu même si celle ci
n'est pas suivi leur interprétation
adéquat était bizarre elles sont
incohérentes avec les mesures les plus
intuitives d'éléments à charge
statistiques qui se déduisent des
paradigmes de la vraisemblance du bail à
nice mme et de la théorie de
l'information
en pratique ces failles prédomine sur
les attributs bénéfiques
dp valurent les règles simples comme le
fait ou non que l'hypothèse nul est
rejetée tonnes une fausse impression de
certitudes une preuve n'est possible que
dans des cadres théoriques comme la
logique et les mathématiques
au lieu de cela la recherche empirique
génère des éléments à charge
nous devons prendre la responsabilité
d'avoir sur simplifier le test
d'hypothèses dans nos cours introductif
avec des règles dichotomique simple
d'acceptation de rejet et le langage de
rejet d'hypothèses nul et de preuves de
l'hypothèse alternative et ainsi de
suite
l'anonymisation des racines de la paix
value et du test d'hypothèses à
contribuer à l'idée qu'elles sont
fournis comme vérité et à encourager
l'utilisation sans réfléchir de ces
procédures
au point d'être mal utilisé et abuser il
ya un besoin pressant d'amener l'analyse
statistique et la prise de décisions
empiriquement fondée au delà du système
actuel de sur test et dessous réflexion
comme beaucoup de chercheurs l'ont
découvert les tests à base de pévèle le
standard ne sont juste pas utile quand
les échantillons de vienne large
puisqu'elles finissent par rejeter
n'importe quelle hypothèse
beaucoup affirment que les principaux
défis concerne la compréhension de la
logique des tests et d'hypothèses
scientifiques et de s'éloigner des
règles mécanique comme p inférieur à
0,05 comme substitut au raisonnement
contextuel ce que nous prétendons c'est
que la logique du test est la mieux
enseigner en premier cours de
statistiques
cependant la recherche en éducation
statistiques montrent clairement que
cette logique est beaucoup plus dure à
enseigner et à apprendre que simplement
p inférieur à 0,05
le fait de s'appuyer sur les tests
statistiques d'hypothèses nul c'est
beaucoup normalisée en psychologie entre
1940 et 1955 et est depuis devenu un
culte ainsi que le fondement d'un large
corpus de recherche corrompus en
business management et dans d'autres
sciences sociales beaucoup de problèmes
surviennent car les affirmations de
significativité sont fondées sur des
règles supposer qu'ils sont abstraites
et trop peureux liées au contexte
d'application
nous prenons que ceux qui en savent plus
sur ce sujet sont proches d'un consensus
sur le fait que les conclusions
scientifiques et les décisions en
politique ou en business ne devrait
presque jamais être fondée sur est-ce
que la paix value passe un seuil
spécifique la paix veille où seul ne
mesure pas la taille des faits ou
l'importance d'un résultat une meilleure
solution n'est pas de changer le seuil
mais de trouver une alternative à
s'appuyer exclusivement sur un seuil le
contexte importe nous a demandé
d'organiser une session et d'écrire un
article sur la question
l'opinion et le jugement des experts ont
ils un rôle dans l'ain ferrand
statistiques et la prise de décisions
empiriquement fondé alors que nous avons
travaillé avec différentes perspectives
et dans différents paradigmes
statistiques à la fois fréquentes east
et bayésiens il y à un oui unanime parmi
nous il est important de reconnaître le
fait qu'une politique de publication
n'est pas parfaite
la science est fondamentalement
difficile et nous devons toujours être
prêt à accepter le fait qu'une certaine
proportion des recherches sera
potentiellement erronées
le plus gros de tous les problèmes avec
l'épée value est peut-être le fait
qu'elles sont souvent mal interprétés
selon des manières qui exagèrent les
éléments à charge contre l'hypothèse nul
malheureusement les chercheurs utilisent
communément des concepts d'inférence
statistiques dont les fondements sont
distendus problème du choix de
traitement l'est devenu particulièrement
comment d'utiliser des tests
d'hypothèses pour comparer des
traitements un objectif central des
tests randomisés clinique est d'informer
les choix de traitement
la convention a été de choisir détail
d'échantillons qui permettent une
puissance statistique spécifié quand on
teste des hypothèses lui désigné à
propos de réponse au traitement contre
des alternatives désigné cependant la
puissance statistique et le test
d'hypothèses son opus peu lié à la prise
en charge efficace du patient alors que
l'épée va lieux sont certainement limité
dans leur champ d'application lité est
difficile à comprendre correctement
beaucoup de critiques sévères jugent ces
statistiques selon des critères
inappropriés ou en comparaison avec des
méthodes sujette à des critiques
parallèle les critiques particulièrement
pernicieuse sont celles qui négligent
comment l'exigence
inférences conclusive peu zappé
n'importe quelle méthode l'utilisation
des p va lui est devenu une épidémie qui
affecte la majorité des disciplines
scientifiques
une action forte est nécessaire à la
fois de la part de la communauté
statistiques et plus généralement de la
communauté scientifique des normes biais
de sélection peuvent rendre n'importe
quoi statistiquement significatifs à
tort et il est très probable que c'est
bien opère dans beaucoup probablement
même la plupart des domaines
scientifiques qui utilisent les paies
value surtout avec un seul tolérant de p
inférieur à 0,05 pour affirmer être un
succès les tests statistiques
d'hypothèses nul et l'épée value sont
les outils fondamentalement les plus
adaptées pour uniquement une minorité de
la recherche actuelle
enfin dans l'éditorial les éditeurs de
journaux écrivent n'y a pas grand chose
que l'on puisse dire ici à propos des
problèmes dp value et des tests
statistiques qui n'ait été dit ailleurs
depuis des décennies si vous débarquez
dans le débat voici un échantillon de ce
qu'il ne faut pas faire ne font des
pavots conclusion uniquement sur une
association ou un effet qui a été
qualifié de statistiquement
significative c'est à dire une paix
value qui passe un seuil arbitraire
comme p inférieur à 0,05
ne croyez pas qu'une association ou
effet existe juste parce qu'il est
statistiquement significative
ne croyez pas qu'une association ou
effet n'existe pas juste parce qu'il
n'est pas statistiquement significatifs
ne croyez pas que votre paie value donne
la probabilité que le hasard seul
produit l'association où les faits
observés ou quelle est la probabilité
que votre test d' hypothèse est vrai ne
concluez lien à propos de l'importance
scientifique ou pratiques d'un test
statistiquement significatifs ou d'un
test statistiquement non significatif
plus de soixante ans de critiques
incisives n'ont pas détrôné le test
statistique d'hypothèses nul en tant
qu'approche dominante de l'inférence
dans de nombreux domaines des sciences
note câline gentleman et coming le
mouvement actuel cependant semble enfin
être du côté de la réforme
les éditeurs du journal conclut et donc
faisant le allons au delà du
statistiquement significatifs vieux
bouleversements et la description sont
inévitables elle
qu'il est et ça vaut le coup dans un
monde au delà de paix inférieur à 0,05
en se libérant des chaînes du
statistiquement significatifs les
statistiques en sciences et en
politiques vont devenir plus
significative que jamais
bon voilà j'espère que ces sites
convaincu à la fois de l'importance des
statistiques pour les sciences et que
les statisticiens sont très mécontents
de l'utilisation des statistiques par
les sciences aujourd'hui et surtout
qu'ils sont très critiques de la méthode
des scientifiques de la méthode
scientifique souvent préconisée et des
affirmations selon lesquelles la science
d'aujourd'hui est la moins mauvaise des
approches possibles la science fait
beaucoup mieux que nos intuitions de
primates
mais elle peut faire beaucoup beaucoup
mieux elle doit faire beaucoup beaucoup
mieux
il est intéressant de noter que les
statisticiens semblent s'accorder sur
plusieurs façons de faire mieux comme
bagnard la terminologie statistiquement
significatifs voire peut-être même la
notion de preuves scientifiques
par ailleurs il semble y avoir un
consensus sur l'importance de la prise
en compte du contexte et de l' expertise
préalable pour bien analyser les données
en termes bayésiens il semble que les
statisticiens souligner toute
l'importance d'avoir des préjugés pour
bien interpréter les données comme le
dit le proverbe bayésiens sans préjugés
aucune conclusion ne peut être tirée
cependant derrière ce consensus assez
marqué vous aurez peut-être ressenti des
points de désaccord entre statisticiens
alors je n'ai pas choisi les citations
et qui souligne au mieux ces désaccords
puis pour les plus motivés je vous
invite vraiment à vous plonger un peu
dedans on est très loin d'un consensus
sur quelles méthodes statistiques
devraient être appliqués en pratique les
articles des uns et des autres se
contredisent souvent est en tout cas un
titre personnel je ne suis vraiment pas
d'accord avec certaines phrases écrites
par certains statisticiens et du coup je
pense qu'il est tout à fait juste de
parler de crise des statistiques
en particulier il semble que toute
méthode statistique est à prendre avec
des pincettes surtout si elle n'est pas
confortée par des théorèmes
mathématiques solide qui démontre les
bonnes propriétés de la méthode
statistique en question bref je vous
invite tous à faire preuve de beaucoup
plus de prudence épistémique pour parler
des statistiques et surtout de la
méthode scientifique qui s'appuie
inéluctablement sur l'analyse de données
ce qu'on appelle également des
statistiques
vient enfin on a parlé de
parapsychologie et de cette étude avec
une paie value largement publiable et
surtout cette méta analyse avec une paie
valu à six sigma qui conclut en rejetant
l'absence de phénomènes
parapsychologiques et donc dit de façon
équivalente qui conclut en le fait qu'il
existe des phénomènes parapsychologiques
et j'avais passé un extrait de rationner
speaking ou massimo pupillo outils
citait les défenseurs du la
parapsychologie et ses défenseurs de la
parapsychologie disait que si ce genre
de résultats était arrivé pour une autre
discipline
alors on aura accepté les résultats ils
en seraient passés à autre chose sinon
art ont fait une remarque que massimi
opinews chef également dans le podcast
mais j'ai coupé vous invite à écouter le
podcast pour avoir tous les détails
leurs remarques commune et le fait que
en fait c'est tout à fait normal qu'il y
ait davantage de scepticisme vis-à-vis
de ce genre de résultat est que l'on ne
passe pas à autre chose parce que ces
résultats sont extraordinaires
or il existe ce fameux proverbe et
éthique de carl sagan et qui est
également un théorème béliziens qui dit
que l'épreuve extraordinaire au caire
des preuves extraordinaires ou pour
reprendre les mots de me suffit des
preuves plus qu'extraordinaire est en
effet c'est une remarque est extrêmement
valide mais il faut bien noter que une
preuve à six sigma c'est quelque chose
de remarquablement extraordinaire
surtout en sciences sociales surtout
psychologique où il est beaucoup plus
commun d'avoir des preuves par p value
avec un petit pays qui est égal à 2%
quelque chose comme ça avoir une paix
valu à 0 0 0 0 0 1%
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui en un
sens est une preuve extraordinaire ne
prouve en tout cas qui sort de
l'ordinaire de la littérature en
psychologie et en fait ce qui est
intéressant avec cet exemple c'est que
finalement on a besoin vraiment de
quantifier à quel point les choses sont
ordinaires ou ou pas et quantifier tout
cela est un travail extrêmement
difficile mais qu'il faut faire au bout
d'un moment et en particulier la paix
value est un indicateur de ça c'est pas
forcément le meilleur des indicateurs
mais un autre point qui est extrêmement
intéressant qui me semblent souvent
négligée c'est le fait de mesurer à quel
point une affirmation est extraordinaire
est ce que l'on entend par le fait
qu'une affirmation est extraordinaire
est ce que par exemple si je vous dis
qu'il y a une probabilité non
négligeable qu'une ya deux niveaux
humain apparaissent avant
2030 est ce que cette affirmation par
exemple est une affirmation
extraordinaire à ce que j'ai besoin de
preuves extraordinaires pour pouvoir
l'affirmer
de prime abord on pourrait vouloir dire
oui cette affirmation est extraordinaire
car elle sort de l'ordinaire bon sens où
c'est pas le genre de phrases que l'on
dit souvent mais ça finalement c'est
vrai de beaucoup beaucoup de choses mais
je vous parle par exemple du principe
d'incertitude d'heisenberg du théorème
de gödel ce sont les affirmations qui en
un sens on également extraordinaire
puisque elles sortent de l'ordinaire en
tout cas du quotidien de la plupart des
personnes donc la notion d'
extraordinaire est en fait beaucoup plus
subtil que ça il s'agit d'une notion qui
est forcément relative à d'autres choses
finalement c'est un adjectif qui est
finalement en fait plus problématique
qu'autre chose
maintenant ce qu'on entend vraiment par
une affirmation extraordinaire c'est
finalement une affirmation qui est très
peu probable a priori alors pour
justifier cela souvent invoque le rasoir
d'occam qui dit que des affirmations
plus simples sont beaucoup plus
ordinaire des affirmations beaucoup plus
compliqués sont plus extraordinaire du
coup mais en fait ce genre de remarque
que ne semble pas vraiment s'appliquer
au cas où tout cas du para psychologique
on en reparlera mais l utilisation du
rasoir d'occam dans beaucoup de cas est
en fait extrêmement bancal et surtout
extrêmement malléable ce qui conduit
beaucoup de personnes du coup à le
manipuler
de sorte à pouvoir conclure ce qu'il
souhaite conclure j'incite un peu sur
tout ça parce que j'ai l'impression que
la réflexion autour de ce qu'est une
infirmation extraordinaire est souvent
très négligée et finalement en tout cas
d'un point de vue bayésiens ça
correspond vraiment à avoir des préjugés
mais ces préjugés ne viennent pas de
nulle part
et en l'occurrence dans le cas de la
parapsychologie ces préjugés en tout cas
mes préjugés avant de découvrir le
résultat de bm même si je ne les avais
pas formule malizé de façon très très
nettes mais les préjugés qui n'était
adéquat pour moi d'avoir avant de
découvrir les résultats de même si
j'avais davantage réfléchi ce sont
vraiment ces préjugés issus de réflexion
autour de la physique théorique et de
l'argument économique jugé 30 et l'anr
fois l histoire qu'ils avaient aimé cet
épisode qui co quasiment l'ensemble des
me critique sur la paix va lui on va
repasser laiterie beaucoup plus balisée
en dur mais en particules appréciation
on va parler de l'un de mes balles ayant
préféré le génialissime alan turing
si vous avez aimé c'est l'épisode
pensait le like et à le commenter à le
partager pensez à vous abonner pour ne
pas manquer de futurs épisodes merci au
team powered ans et j'espère qu'il
serait là la prochaine fois la requête
trou du sexting
m